hi everyone thank you so much for coming
to see me I know you had many many one
other choice to go see and really quick
let me just can I get some smiling faces
for my Instagram okay let's see just
finish speech they loved it I my name is
Alex Kaminski I live in Brooklyn New
York as she said and a little bit about
me I am the lead creative engineer at
Reuters TV if you've never heard of it
Reuters TV it's a personalized video
news app we are out on iOS Android Apple
TV and of course web when I join Reuters
TV the web app was not yet built and I
was the first engineer hired to build it
I met with my bosses my first week and I
quickly realized they knew roughly what
I needed to build but they had no strong
opinions about how I should build it
what technologies we should use or even
how the process within the team should
be structured it was all up to me
or for you I sunders pop it's a lot of
pressure it's at the same time very
exciting and intimidating to be in this
situation I'm sure a lot of us have
joined teams later in the life cycle of
a product and thought we do things
differently maybe certain aspects of the
tech are outdated or the process within
the other teams is dysfunctional this
was my chance to make sure this didn't
happen and thus I was faced with the
first engineers dilemma so put yourself
in my shoes you know roughly what you
need to build and you have complete
freedom as to how to do it what sort of
decisions do we need to make as first
engineers to make sure that they don't
bite you in the ass down the line so I
looked in my situation and I saw two
distinct categories of dilemma the first
word dilemmas of workflow how do you we
first engineers insert ourselves into
organizations what sort of relationships
do we need to build with designers
product owners CEOs people like that and
the other obvious type of dilemma is the
technical kind we all know the absolute
insane number of options we have to
build web apps in the modern age how do
you begin to pick a full text back top
to bottom that's not going to feel
completely outdated in just a few months
so during the rest of this talk I am
going to talk to you about how I
navigated all these questions believe me
I did not get them all right and
hopefully this won't just apply to those
of you who are starting at a new company
but also for side projects and
freelancers too so let's talk about
design before I even considered which
technologies I was going to use on my
project I wanted to set the tone with
design and just a quick shout out the
app was designed by anas landok firm way
know who are here in the audience so
shout out to them so many places I've
worked at design and technology have
been completely siloed and for me this
approach is really frustrating for two
reasons the first is that interpreting
PSD's or sketch files without any
context can lead to frustration on
everyone's part you know designers they
don't often think about all the
different breakpoints and browsers and
other weird edge cases that we know
we're going to have to deal with and the
second reason I get frustrated is
without technology being involved
upfront in design a lot of designers
won't know how far they can push it we
wouldn't all be here at this conference
if we didn't like staying up to date
with the most cutting-edge technology
and I'm guessing there are a lot of
strict designers in the house so if we
don't bring that knowledge that we get
here up up front in the process it
doesn't translate into the finished
product and I was hired at Reuters TV to
push that envelope so getting to work
with design closely from the beginning
was very important so when I proposed
this to the team I noticed two things
and the first was that design was
thrilled to be working this way I think
when us passionate technologists and
designers get together
wapping what we've seen and what's cool
on the web magic things can happen that
get lost in that delivery of static
files but the second thing I noticed is
that it doesn't work for everyone our
iOS team was already happily underway
with this more pipeline approach just
reading sketch files and I'll give you
that the Zeppelin plugin for sketch has
made it really easy for developers to
more accurately interpret static files
so now our two teams work completely
differently with design and it actually
ends up working great for us because web
gets to work all the way up with design
and we get to prototype and figure out
all the kinks and weird stuff with a
feature before it gets shipped at the
iOS team so we get to sort of be on the
vanguard of new features and then the
iOS team who needs to respect at pushes
with Apple gets to get more polished
sketch file from design so the
relationship with product owners is
equally important to build early on as
the first engineer on all the projects
I've worked on over the years the ones
where technologies had a big seat at the
table when coming up with which features
to work on how they're going to work and
more my new details like that they've
been the best ones to work on so as the
first engineer on a project it's in your
vest in interest to insert yourself into
that decision making process as far as
possible so to do that you have to win
over these project owners and how do you
do it my strategy is simple don't be
that no developer that we've all been at
some point in our career where you're
just sick of everything you think
everything stupid and you're set in your
ways don't be that guy in your first few
weeks at a company get excited about the
features on the roadmap even if you're
not and actively engage those product
stakeholders during your build process
so your first few weeks should be about
prototyping actively show up demos and
progress to these people and make
everyone feel like progress is being
made you know if you're slogging around
in the back end and not showing anything
that's easily visible to these people a
lot of times they'll get frustrated and
think that's nothing's getting done
so prototyping allows you to build trust
with these people as well as by see some
time to figure out which technologies
you want to use on your project speaking
of technology it's one of the biggest
decisions you'll make as the first
engineer and it's also sort of the
Genesis for this talk now I'm sure a lot
of us have stepped on a projects and
wondered who the hell made the call to
use some weird library or framework or
old ass tank and the truth is that
decision can usually be traced all the
way back to that first engineer and
we're not going to make that mistake
this time so to help me I've developed
something called the new technology
quadrant theory and it's basically just
a framework for evaluating frameworks or
other libraries or technologies are
interested in and bringing on your
project so before including anything but
basic HTML CSS and JavaScript on your
project I run the technology through
these four quadrants to decide if it
fits the bill now my first question I
look at is friendliness to new
developers as a community we JavaScript
engineers have one of the biggest pools
of developers to draw on out of any
other language but we lose that if we
choose these niche technologies that
shut people out so as the first engineer
who may be hiring new developers I want
to make sure I'm able to cast a wide net
and choose technologies that are going
to be easily accessible to people so the
first quadrant or answer I'm looking to
satisfy is am i comfortable hiring
someone who's never worked with this
before on to my project my second
quadrant is sexiness working on new and
compelling technology makes us happier
at our jobs every day likewise it makes
it easier to attract that new talent
when it does come time to find that
second engineer so sexiness and choosing
good technologies that you're actually
interested in is equally important my
third quadrant is my ability to lead on
it as the first engineer it's going to
be expected that you know the ins and
outs of the project and the tech stack
new engineers are going to be looking to
you for decisions on how to style build
and execute on features and that's why
it's important to use technologies that
are familiar to you or at least you have
the ability to get up to speed quickly
if not
finally I look at production readiness
one of the dangers of choosing something
in the sexy category is that it's buggy
or its api's are changing really rapidly
so in addition you want to pick a
technology that's got a good base
community in case you do get into those
sticky situations and you need to turn
the stack overflow so a good rule of
thumb as the first engineer is to keep
the stack to just a few newer workhorse
frameworks that are going to help you
build out the app until the product
requirements dictate otherwise so now
that I've played out the general
strategy for evaluating technologies I'm
going to take you through how I pick the
stack for Reuters so let's start with
something easy CSS pre-processing
everyone knows there's two major players
in this camp sass and less I ran them
through quadrant 3 and they both came
out about dead even I've used both
extensively in the past I know they're
production-ready new developer friendly
and I'm able to write good code with
both so without with both about dead
even I was free to make a gut call and
that's one of the luxuries you have as
the first engineer I ultimately sell
around less for my team but let's talk
about something way more difficult which
is choosing JavaScript technologies it's
the elephant in the room at these
conferences choosing what frameworks to
use and there have been many many talks
which discussed the merits of each
framework and why you should use it I'm
not going to go into all that but I will
discuss how I approach the problem and
ultimately went with the technologies I
did so looking back at quadrant theory
one of them to look at railway is your
own ability to lead on a framework and
in my case i'd recently shipped three
major projects in ember angular and
react given as the lead developer on a
project i want to feel confident in the
decisions I'm making about architecture
I decided to go down the road with one
of these three so how about sexiness I
know one of the reasons I was lured to
Reuters was that I got to help build
that team and a big part of attracting
that talent is that good tech stack so
the new hotness was angular is angular 2
and I never worked with that before and
the api's and the language itself is
extremely different so that eliminated
that one for me
just left me with reactant ember now
both of these frameworks are proven to
scale Facebook and Instagram use react
apple and Heroku and others use ember so
production readiness wasn't really an
issue and that just left friendliness to
new developers and truth be told I do
feel like ember is a friendlier language
to new door library to new developers
because when you first see it jsx looks
weird but quadrant theory does leave
something important out and that is
context now Reuters TV is not a
data-driven application it's really just
the view of the MVC and there's no
writing to a database at all the entire
application is driven by these tiny
little UI components that have localized
in global states it's really just a
pretty video player and wouldn't you
know it Facebook created react kind of
to solve this exact issue so given the
context of my application I decided to
build it out and react it fit the bill
exactly for what my app needed but the
new developer bit the new developer
friendliness bugged me a bit what
exactly about react made it so
complicated so I began to think about
this question and I realized for me it
wasn't react itself that was complicated
it was actually the flux and Redux
architecture that the whole community
seems to evangelize almost every guide
to beginning react today involves
starting with some build tool rolling up
a very foreign application architecture
if you've never used flux and react
before and did I really need all that
for Reuters and the answer was no so in
the first few months of building Reuters
I build it out on a very lean list of
libraries react a few utility libraries
and web pack to package it all together
and my application was fast simple and
easy to understand and I felt like I
could easily get someone who's never
used react up to speed quickly and to
this day we still use this flux list
react stack to great success and I
challenge you to think about everything
you're bringing on before importing just
what school at the moment in the
community
so unlike you all I did not have the
benefit of seeing this talk before
making these decisions and not
everything went out that a hitch when I
chose the build system for my app I went
over my options just like I did for
JavaScript and my decision-making came
down to grunt gulp or web pack now I was
already familiar with grunt and gulp but
webpack was the new hot thing on the
market and I decided to go against
quadrant theory and use web pack despite
not knowing anything about it and long
story short my team is still learning
and grappling with web pack I don't
regret the decision to use it it's got a
lot of pros and cons but I have had some
embarrassing moments where I haven't
known a quick fix for my team that I
absolutely would have if I'd use grunt
or Goulburn something I knew now luckily
I made this mistake with our build
system and not our actual application
structure but it does go to show the
importance of understanding technologies
you decide to use on your own projects
so the final thing you need to do after
you figure out how you're going to work
with design and product and which
technologies you're going to use is set
good standards for your team for the
developers to come and for your own
development one of the first things I
did after choosing this text deck was
work out the style guides for my team
and I had to come up with answers for
the following how are we going to
standardize CSS how do we style it and
document our JavaScript what does our
actual project structure look like and
how do I enforce it all and make sure
that my developers are speaking the same
language so just like everything in our
community a lot of people have a lot of
opinions about standardized CSS naming
conventions and now there are some very
strict systems out there like them and I
think these are great for massive teams
that need a lot of structure however to
me bem felt like overkill for my product
I felt like it ultimately would have
slowed me down during a period where I
needed to be prototyping and really
throwing out features quickly to show
progress and demonstrate confidence to
my team so instead i opted for something
out of one of my favorite TV character
Ron Swanson's
playbook straight down the middle no
hook no fuss anything more and this
becomes figure skating so translating
that that mantra to CSS I came up with
this dash is not underscores tabs not
spaces no nesting more than three deep
and just one file per component and this
is where great for my team now figuring
out the style guide for javascript was
my next dilemma to wrestle with and as
with choosing my JavaScript framework I
weighed the context of my app heavily
when deciding how to enforce JavaScript
style with my team now if my app was a
lot of boilerplate and standard app
structures and BC sort of stuff I could
have gotten away with your some sensible
variable and method naming conventions
and some selective comments on edge
cases however as I said my application
is really highly custom and all about
these little UI components that aren't
much boilerplate at all so for this
reason I decided to enforce a much more
robust commenting structure to help
everyone stay on the same page so when I
reflected on projects I've worked on
from a style perspective I immediately
gravitated towards the school go project
I'd work on and while I didn't enjoy
closure much I did appreciate the fact
that all the developers on the project
we're speaking the exact same language
and all the codes seemed to come from
the same developer when I think when all
the code feels consistent it's easier to
read and you can get in this rhythm of
understanding and that can get broken
when you're dealing with different
blocks of code written in different
styles so I adopted a lot from their
style guide when defining how to write
JavaScript on Reuters and it's been
immensely helpful now that we have
several developers working on the
JavaScript code base so as you can see
it's sort of like a.j s doc style
comments and it really helps define what
every little method and variable does so
another subject that doesn't get a lot
of love is directory structure and it's
one of those decisions that you can sort
of put off and before you know it you
have this gnarly directory with tons
files to sort through and it's just
another decision that's going to be
highly dependent based on your framework
or build system and the context of your
application but this is how i went about
it one of the niftiest things about web
pack is it takes a lot of the stress
about complicated dependencies out of
building an app you can import style
sheets images and other dependencies
directly into your JavaScript files
creating these neat little bundles for
your components as if importing your
HTML into your JavaScript wasn't enough
with react so given that I was already
on the component game plan with react I
decided to build out my project into
just these little self-contained modules
so each major component gets its own
directory smaller sub components can
live under them and all the dependencies
live into these directories so here you
can see a javascript file and a less
file under its own directory and as a
project grew in size ended up further
segmenting these components down by
their view sidebar in this case is
shared so it lives in the shared folder
so after you've figured out all the
styles that you want to enforce on your
project it's not just going to happen
overnight with code reviews and telling
your team how you'd like them to do it
nicely so I turned to linting to help
enforce them on my team and in the past
I was familiar with closure compiler and
Jas lint but now I was leveraging newer
syntax with react in es6 on my project
and these didn't quite fit the mold
anymore so after some research i found
es lint and that's been a fantastic tool
for my team it allows you to really
customize which rules you want to
enforce and how you want to enforce them
and even automatically fix them in your
build process a final thing I did as the
first engineer as the cherry on top to
help bring all my style and structure
decisions together was to create a
boilerplate template for new components
I was inspired by rails or angular
scaffolding which allows you to quickly
create and generate new components which
automatically fit the style and
structure of your application it's just
a useful little touch you can do as the
first engineer that will speed up your
own career
of new components as well as give other
developers a jumpstart to creating their
own features that match your projects
feng shui so I've just touched on all
the basic dilemmas that you're going to
encounter is the first engineer and
every organization is a totally
different beast but just to recap I'm
going to give you a battle plan to help
you if you ever find yourself as the
first engineer at a company so I'm going
to break it into three phases the first
phase is really about finding you're
finding yourself within the organization
you need to define your relationship
with design and I mean you should get up
and close with them and prototype and
get on top of the features and really
take an active role in defining what you
guys are going to build you're going to
find yourself way more invested in the
product and you're going to find that
the end results are much better and you
can use this time to while you're
prototyping to show it off and build
trust with product owners CEOs people
like that who are going to be really
impressed by you and want to give you a
seat at the decision-making table when
deciding sort of where your product is
going to go and you're going to use this
phase where you're prototyping and
looking at the features to look at the
big picture requirements for your app
and it's going to help you make informed
technical decisions in the second phase
which is choosing technologies and here
you want to think about your CSS
preprocessors your JavaScript frameworks
or build system and you can use that
quadrant theory i showed you to help
rule stuff out and just rule of thumb to
start be lean and rely on just a few
workhorse frameworks that are tried and
true and they're going to help you
through the day finally phase 3 is just
about building standards for your team
set CSS styles set JavaScript styles and
stick to them you're really going to
thank yourself ten years from now when
your code base is still maintainable and
it's you're able to bring new developers
on easily think about your directory set
up early don't wait to the last minute
or else it'll be a jumbled mess and
finally find a way to enforce it besides
just telling developers how you'd like
it I use linting on my project it works
pretty well it's
automatically part of our build process
and I first I dreaded those little red
dots popping up on my coat every day but
now I actually look forward to it
because the code is really clean even
when another developer touches it so
thank you so much for coming to see me I
hope this was helpful and I really hope
you guys enjoy your stay in Iceland
thanks